hello everyone how's it going I hope you
all had a great GGC experiences today
and welcome to firebase what we talk
about mobile gaming experiences and how
we can make it better for you hi I'm Jen
I'm the hours tech lead sorry I think I
don't have the click there you go
hi I'm Tara I'm the Iowa tech lead for
firebase club messaging I'm here today
with two of my Google colleague Patrick
and sumit so yeah my name is Patrick
Martin I'm a developer advocate based
out of Boulder Colorado I actually have
a degree in game development and I've
spent the last decade or so building
mobile games and ultra robotic toys
and I'm sooo much ndele spent a number
of years at Google developer advocating
a lot of different products including
Google web toolkit AdWords API Android
wear and most recently firebase so we're
pretty excited about sharing with you
how firebase can help with your game
development and with that I'll throw it
back to Jen awesome thank you guys so
there's three parts to the talk first
we're gonna give an overview about
firebase along with some of the latest
updates and I'm gonna invite Patrick
back on stage to show you how to build
the game with firebase and cloud
services Patrick can cover some of the
new features coming up this year so it's
gonna be a great technical overview and
then we're gonna bring a sumit back on
stage to show you how to grow your users
driving player engagement is a critical
part of the business so stay tuned for
that so what is firebase right on a
higher level
firebase is Google cloud specialized
mobile and web app development platform
let me give you a little bit background
if you come here to any of the Google
cloud talk today you probably already
know that the Google cloud is a powerful
tool right it is built on cutting-edge
technologies in both hardware and
software infrastructure it is also
platform agnostic because no matter what
platform your games are at GCP can
support the right company can be your
backbone because we move the burden of
proving
and managing your own server and it
provides a variety of tools right to
help you to scale so tools like App
Engine cloud storage bigquery tensorflow
and many many other tools right is very
powerful and it provides reliable and
secure connections so you can safely
deploy your code to the cloud so what is
firebase right firebase is built on top
of the GCP and the it is specialized in
mobile and web applications so if you
build a mobile game or web app for base
is more tailored to your experiences
because we focus on many of the common
problems engineering problems that
mobile developers facing right and also
we provide customer a P is that so your
app can easily communicate with the GCP
the Google cloud platform so in a way
that will provide quicker path to get
you started out GCP so here's the
substance of the far based products that
we don't talk to you about today as you
can see firebase deliver solutions
throughout the entire lifecycle right
from building a game improve the quality
to engage more users and driving player
retentions right and no matter what you
10 size is right it could be one person
startup or enterprise level companies
right we have tools that can support any
use cases and our products also focus on
many aspects of the business right if
you are engineer and you know like the
focus on problem like how do I do this
more efficiently right or how do i scale
so we have tools like that so for
example if you send in push
notifications we have cloud messaging
and then if you want to do a signup flow
we have authentication or if you wanna
how do i do a build a server list
infrastructure right we have GCP tools
like cloud storage and fire store right
and these are the critical components of
building a game app right and that's why
what engineers was focus on and the
firebase provide tools so that you can
help you to save and they take the cost
and they also help you to build
infrastructure so you don't have to do
that if you're Prada manager right you
wonder how does my game are performed
right you you want to understand your
users better so we have tools like that
as well like analytics
be testing Opie Cory right a lot of
products can export picori easily so you
can do deep analysis on GCP and you can
also run experiments right to understand
your users better while making the
product decisions and lastly if you have
QA team right we got great who's there
to cover like any aspects of improving
your apps quality like crashlytics
performance and test lab later in the
session zoom in and Patrick will do a
deep dive on some of the youth k to show
how exactly you can do this and what's
the best about purpose and GCP is that
they work well together right under the
hood they have the same project and same
building account so it's very easy for
you to manage and if your cloud customer
you can improve your project to firebase
instantly and menu our firebase products
are already running on GCP such as cloud
storage first door and cloud function so
anything with a cloud so say you're
first-time users what do you get outside
this firebase package right let me help
you to visualize it so first you get a
firebase council it serve as a developer
control panel right it is where you set
up a new project and you can configure a
monitoring your firebase services and
then you get a bunch of ice decay right
you pick and choose the one you need
installed in your game and you're wrong
a bunch of code to quickly enable
functionalities and that the client will
make a secure connection to the firebase
service on the cloud and to the council
so you always think up together right
and the best part is you don't have to
build any of the infrastructure right
and they it is secure it's scalable oh
and one more thing
firebase the council is also grateful
for your game designers or marketing
people if you do one like monitor data
or added game contents and will provide
a variety of SDKs if for majority of the
developers here the game developer we
have super pass and unity cross-platform
SDKs and if you are iOS and Android
developer like me we have that as well
and lastly our web SDKs suppose both
and web applications Furbys was launched
since 2016 and over three years we've
seen tremendous growth to this day we
have over 1.5 million monthly active
users apps and devorah shooting us
because a firebase is easy to use it's
powered by Google cloud technology and
integrates well with many cross-platform
and third-party tools now have some new
updates for you if your unity developer
now the onboarding flow has become
easier for you previously when you set
about unity cross platform SDK a project
you have to set up twice you have to go
to the iOS platform study it up and do
it again
enjoy now we get this shiny unity button
if you click on it now I can set up both
your iOS and Android app at the same
time and downloaded configuration files
and the import to your project and
finish with downloading the Unity SDK
again it's quick and easy lastly I want
to talk a bit about open source a
firebase will really value the
transparency of our SDK we understand
that it is important for the developers
to know the exact behavior of our source
code especially when it comes to how we
handle the user privacy and data which
is why we're excited that our CIPA pass
SDK is also open source now now if you
Superbus developer you can choose to
integrate one of our open source sdk
with a source code accessible it
provides great flexibility in your
development flow right first you can
order your source code and make
modifications at your own pace and the
firebase open source community has
continued to grow over the years right
and more and more SDKs from different
platform have been open source and now
you can help contribute back to the
community you can be part of it right
first you can help
pour the SDK to a different platform
that we don't support or you can help
making contribution to the existing SDK
by adding new features or fixing issues
now I'm sure
all got excited about using firebase in
your games I'm gonna pass that Patrick
to talk about it hi everybody thanks Jen
for that introduction and what I want to
talk to you now is how to build what
it's like to build a game in firebase
and I think kind of what will make this
easier for everyone to understand if I
first as if I first gave you guys a
little bit of background from where I'm
coming from so for the past couple of
years I've been doing a lot of research
and development and prototyping and it
was the kind of thing where you know I'd
have a few days maybe a week to throw a
whole bunch of stuff together get a
concept off the ground and get a
testable and I didn't need that test to
like live past the meeting where I got
approved or something so I used a very
different stack than it did back when I
worked on kind of asynchronous
multiplayer games you know if you ever
work on something like that you kind of
need your servers to be accessible all
the time 24/7 and for any play length
and the tools to achieve each one of
these is are typically completely
different sets you'll normally rip
everything up from your prototyping and
do something brand new in production and
I would say that yes there we go the job
of every developer every game developer
is really to find the fun whether you're
in pre-production post production are
working on a game your users aren't
paying you for like just pretty graphics
or cool tech it's something fun that
they can enjoy and firebase I think
helps shorten the distance from any idea
you have in your head to being able to
actually experiment in iterate on it and
not only is this then backed by Google's
cloud platform is Chen mentioned but if
for whatever reason firebase doesn't
meet your needs once you scale up from
prototyping to production you do have
the full brute force of Google's cloud
behind you and you can work directly
there if that's where your needs
q so I want to kind of show you what
it's like building a game really quickly
using actually single player game called
mecha hamster which is our it's our
testing project for firebases unity
integration so mecha answer is really
simple it's like one of those old wooden
marble maze games you just tilt your
phone and get hammer the hamster to the
end of this maze up here yeah pretty
simple I'm sure you guys all get it and
what I'm going to do is enhance this
single-player game by giving it kind of
a cloud back-end with secure and shared
data in it that I probably wouldn't want
to risk otherwise if I didn't have
something like firebase to host it on so
the way we decided to start expanding
this game was to build our own level
editor
the basic idea behind it is the you know
normally a designer would have to go
through the entire devstack
to get a build onto a phone to test it
which could sometimes take minutes and
then other people wouldn't necessarily
get to play unless you walked over to
their desk or you pulled it down from a
build server so we really wanted to
build something that you know you could
work on on the phone press play test it
instantly and just share it out to the
whole team really quickly like at the
press of a button and since these levels
are just like a 2d grid it's a very easy
thing to serialize store and interact
with so we decided to use firebase is
real time database this represents all
of the data in your database is
effectively a very large JSON document
which I know some people love json some
people hate it the point isn't that
you're writing JSON but the many
languages and game engines like unity
can serialize to and from it just as a
library function so you know we just hit
a node with the JSON serialize or get
all the data out into a database and
I want to focus on the real-time bit
just a little bit if this isn't real
time like you know 30 frames a second
like a video game but this is real time
enough that you could do something like
Google Docs
you know collaborative editing I I find
that sometimes I can even type on one
computer and look at another and kind of
know what I'm doing in a Google Doc you
could do the same sort of
synchronization and a level editor if
you built out the UI for it but the
other really cool thing a real-time
database does for you is cache
everything so if you're offline if you
like drove through a tunnel while you're
working on a level all your rights are
still instant to the database so you can
use the database provided in our SDK
it's kind of your single source of truth
and then whenever you go back online
your local copy doesn't get stomped with
the web and the web copy doesn't get
stomped with your local copy we just
replay the transactions you made while
you're offline which is kind of a nice
way to protect against data loss as
you're doing these migrations it's kind
of a hard problem if like you've ever
had to implement this on your own and a
cool thing that came out of all this
work to build a level editor is a well
we're at world Game Developers right
we're at the game developer conference
I'm sure we all had that moment when we
realized that games are not magical
plastic discs that appeared in like a
game store right or in my case
cartridges for me the moment that I
realized this was when I found the quake
one level editor and I started making
actually really bad maps where only on
you the cool weapon drops or like
sniping positions or something so why
couldn't we enable fans of Mecca hamster
to express their creativity like that
and maybe you know join us in the
creative process and even though we're
storing this data and the cloud we're
able to confidently enable this kind of
curated user sharing with this rules
language that we have with real-time
database this is just a JSON object with
annotations that lay parallel to your
database
and they're relatively simple I actually
simplified this a bit more just so it
fits on the slide but here we're just
saying the node map list is readable by
the entire Internet
but by changing this to the string off
not equals to no we guarantee that any
user trying to read this map list will
only get it if they are logged in and
these statements you put here can be
JavaScript expressions so you can't
enforce rules like only the creator of a
map can use it until they mark it as
shared stuff like that and where the
auth came from is actually from firebase
authentication in mecca hamster we opted
to use email address and password
account management as well as something
called anonymous sign on anonymous
sign-on in particular might sound weird
but all it's doing is store as a
associating your device with the account
instead of like a username and password
and later on if the user wants to share
their data between devices they can
migrate up to a email address account
you can of course opt out of signing in
if you just don't want these online
features and I should stress that this
email address password authentication
isn't me being silly and thinking I can
implement my own like sign and logic
with like all the security issues
associated with this this is a firebase
product and has all of googles security
guarantees but we also support all these
other authentication providers now if
you're prototyping and you're just
trying to get an idea off the ground as
fast as you can is email address and
password but all you have to do is
integrate the client SDK is for each one
of these auth providers and we need
everything else in the cloud for you you
know validating the user token we even
let you merge and migrate accounts so
Game Center on iOS is a new integration
if you added it to your app you could
allow your users to add that to their
account and all of a sudden they have a
new way of signing on that it doesn't
require them to start again from scratch
so another thing we wanted to do is ID
leaderboards to make a hamster this is
super common and games and it's so
common that we just made an open-source
so it can go up here grab the source
code for a sample leaderboard
integration actually start trying start
playing with real time database right
now in your existing game writing just a
minimal amount of CO code get your feet
wet decide whether or not it's right for
you so that's at firebase extended /
unity solutions so we wanted to augment
our our leaderboard though with user
replays now for something for reasons
that might become apparent later in my
talk we had replay recording and Mecca
hamster so we decided we'd show how
people got yeah how people we wanted to
show how people got the high scores that
they had and you know you might just
think hey I'm gonna use JSON serializer
and unity and just dump whatever data
structure I have for the replays into
the real time database but it turns out
even compressed in a flat buffer these
replays are around 30 to 60 kilobytes
and at some point the real time is not
real time just because you're passing a
lot of data and also you don't want to
collaboratively edit replays that to me
that sounds more like cheating than a
feature so we needed somewhere large as
you saw to store this replay data and we
decided to use cloud storage for
firebase now this is another database
it's a key value storage where the key
is just any path so logically order this
however you want and the value is really
anything you want to put up there you
know videos player avatars in our case
you know replays and the flow for
uploading a high score now becomes you
know you add the high score to the high
score table there's an extra node there
for the replay will live you start
asynchronously uploading the replay data
you get a call back when that completes
it can just update the note in the
leaderboard to point to your replay
there is one problem with this though
now that we have two databases when a
high scores
no longer our high score the replay data
will leak so we use something called
cloud functions to listen for when
there's a change in this case a create
event in the real-time database and that
happens we check how many high scores
there are for the map you're on knock
off the lowest if there are more than
five and clean up the Associated replay
data so cause functions are actually a
really awesome tool for someone like me
who's lived mostly in the client space
they're just now out of beta for
firebase and they let you run mobile
backend code without managing the
servers again if I'm prototyping this is
an awesome shortcut to get to our one
need to be and it is still on like you
know Google's cloud infrastructure so
this these are reliable and scalable you
write these in JavaScript or typescript
and you have the full you know NPM
package manager to do it so you can
really go crazy here they're still
secure so firebase authentication still
applies off not equals snow is a valid
way to check if a user's login and the
user is guaranteed to not be spoofing
their like user token or something by
now and these let you not only
communicate between different firebase
products but also between the firebase
in the web so just some examples of what
you might use these foreign games if you
have like asynchronous multiplayer board
games rather than just trusting players
to not claim that they roll nat 20s all
the time you know they're the Gandalf of
Monopoly or something you can push your
die rolls off into a cloud function if
you have a gadget mechanic in your game
you know you can use the cloud function
to make sure they have enough capsules
or whatever subtract one roll the loop
but if you're using something like
crashlytics from firebase you can
actually listen for a new crash to
happen in the wild and actually
automatically file a JIRA for your team
maybe if I crash spikes and occurrence
you send a message like the SOS channel
on your slap on your team slack and
everyone starts rallying around it so
now it's time to ship a game
right and the thing that keeps me up at
night whenever hit go is when that
inevitable review comes in that says
game is a blank screen on launch or
crashes on launch it like you know
worked on all our devices in the task in
the queue a test lab but there's just
something in the wild we kind of take
account of so you really need to run
your game on actual hardware you need to
test various OS and hardware
combinations because even if you're
using test-driven development something
like you're using a feature in a shader
that's not supported will still cause a
failure compilation error actually once
had a game as black blank screen on
launch because the OpenGL context
claimed that it supported a level of
anti-aliasing that actually didn't and
it just failed to create my context for
me and you really want these to be
automatic you like not just a human
going through you want to be able to
shove these up to a server where some
cadence built into like your build
pipeline and be able to know the at the
very moment a build fails
so for mecha hamster we're using Robo
tests and fire based test lab now mecha
hamster didn't have many unit tests and
at least my experience in the industry
that is really common in video games but
with Robo test we can just upload the
production apk and well the way I like
to imagine it is a friendly little robot
walks into your game kind of stares at
your view hierarchy and then presses all
the buttons as fast as it possibly can
until it crashes or it times out and
this will run on real hardware there's
like literally like racks of phones or
something in a data center somewhere and
what's really cool about this especially
for the kind of test it does it might be
hard for me to reproduce I might CNR the
bug just because like it required
tapping in a specific spot in the splash
screen or something so it records the
video shows you little circles of where
this robot was interacting you get the
stack trace if it crashed you get the
log of like everything that happened
leading up to it and you know that this
ran on
kind of a clean environment there's not
like that weird app that kills
applications in the background to
theoretically save battery life or
something this is like just a stock
device that you're running this on but
some engineers in the room might have
noticed that I said this robot walks
around and looks at your view hierarchy
and we're game developers our view
hierarchy is probably just a GL context
so this seems kind of useless so of
course we decided to use our AI chops to
create something that we call a I
assisted monkey testing this uses
machine vision to look at the output of
your game like a human find things that
look interactable usually buttons and
concentrate the random presses at these
buttons so you don't have to expose your
custom UI to Robo test or in this case a
eye system monkey testing to get a
useful test as you see here the AI
assisted monkey testing video is already
to the logical end of this unit test
whereas the Robo test is still clicking
around in some corner of the screen
somewhere if anything else this is just
a safety net for your existing QA team
you don't have to do any additional
integration your apk this is running on
actual hardware in a data center as I
pointed out or on virtual devices if you
want to test like weird OS or screen
combinations and yeah it's pretty cool I
had another bullet point but yeah I
already went over it so there's another
kind of unit testing though that I we
usually called it like demo loops or
like a profiling test and firebase test
lab we call it game loops and the
general idea of this is that you know
what parts of the game you need to
hammer you know how to load all the
shaders get a bunch of geometry on
screen and not only do you want to see
if phones will run it without crashing
but you might also want to profile this
and make sure you're hitting your men
frame rate targets on all your devices
and kind of build up a list of which
devices you need like a lower
performance profile on or something so
once again you upload your production
apk to the cloud
run on real devices that span the range
of low-end to like you know flagship
phones and the way this works in a
production environment is it sends
something called an intent which if
you're not familiar with native Android
dev like you're just coming from a unity
background this is basically a
command-line argument but to an Android
app and I've spent a lot of time in
unity I wasn't quite sure how I get this
in so when I looked at mecha hamster I
found like this game loop class game
loop manager class I'm not sure where it
came from it's actually from this code
lab it's very easy to follow if you if
you're already profile or use demo loops
I'd recommend walk through this and you
just instantly grow your QA test pool
for this sort of thing again even if you
don't want to do this if you want to put
the minimum amount of effort possible
into testing now I'm not saying that's a
bad thing but sometimes it's the reality
just upload your apk now you just gave
your QA an extra little bit of safety
net as they go through their normal
approval process so you're still gonna
have crashes in the field you can't
catch everything again there's like that
crazy app that kills games in the
background and people root their phones
and all this other stuff you're still
going to need crash reporting and
crashlytics is a kind of a really neat
way to gather crashes from the field and
sort them by like frequency device type
OS version everything you need to stock
traces as well everything you need to
not only figure out why a crash happened
but see if it's something you need to
address because the reality is the some
phones will just have a marginal market
chair right and if he cannot reliably
fix the crash in a short amount of time
if this phone is like a fraction of a
percent of your market it may be more
fiscally pertinent to just blacklist on
the Play Store but when brand new
flagship phone comes out your games
crashing all the time on it this
actually happened to
when the first mobile multi-core phones
came out you can if you have that cloud
functions hook running you might get a
spike in the SOS channel like this bug
is happening a whole lot and you can
rally your team around make sure you get
that pre-order in and start testing on
the new phone if that if that happens to
you and crashlytics is now integrated
with unity which is really awesome to me
again in the past would happen as I'd
get like the C++ stack trays and I'd
have to bring that into the il-2 cpp
output and then try to figure out what
c-sharp generated that which was kind of
a process there were helpful guides for
it but it took me a little bit of time
in this case I accidentally cleared a
field and a game object and I got a
stack trace and Pasha lytx almost
instantly I was refreshing like the
dashboard that showed me exactly where
to look to find this and in this case
this isn't even a bug I would have made
it as a programmer this or I could have
made as a programmer but also a designer
or an artist might have made this or it
could have just happened from like
version control so crashlytics is pretty
much a free integration if you're
already using firebase so you might as
well just drop it in and again for a
little bit of extra safety net just to
bump the quality of your app up a little
higher with that I'm gonna hand this
over to sumit to talk to you about
growth alright y'all so we built the
game we shipped the game and now it's
time to grow the game now when you're
growing your game there's two drue
there's the traditional marketing
methods and teams that your company or
startup might be using where they run a
campaign and try to grow your player or
user base and there's a lot of different
tools and innovations available to those
teams there and that's probably
something you want to continue to use
that however is different than what I
wanted to talk about here in the context
of firebase developer services and
Google cloud so within the developer
context what you want to be able to kind
of do is easily a be test new features
right so you've shipped your game you
know where you're at now and you want to
kind of figure out
as you release new features are they
good or bad are they been received and
certainly you want to damage what you've
already released right so you want to be
able to easily a/b test and then
furthermore measure the results of those
a/b tests as well to determine their
effectiveness personally I'm still a be
testing whether Gregory's coffee
Starbucks coffee or third rail coffee
makes more productive in the morning
results so far inconclusive
alright so I'll set the stage with this
question right or there's an opening use
case of how can I track how my game is
doing now and how can I easily test new
features and see if those are good so
we'll look at the first part of this
question first which is how can I track
how my game is doing now okay so the
track their game is doing you've got to
look at data and depending on the type
of game that you have and the number of
players we could be talking about a lot
of data so take for example a massively
multiplayer online RPG game where you're
not just logging single events of users
tapping on your screen or you know
interacting with their game as single
events that are getting recorded but
you're collecting a stream of events
over a long interval of time maybe a few
hours right in that kind of game a
player might be interacting with other
players in the game and you're logging
that they might be buying selling or
trading items and you're logging those
they might be completing quests or
accepting new missions or taking a
certain direction on your map and these
are all events that you're collecting
right over hours for one player now
imagine if you've got thousands or
millions of players that's a lot of data
that you're collecting so hence the
image of this data center to kind of
represent
a whole lot of data for example on one
of Google services that relies on this
so that's where Google Cloud bigquery
can come in so if you're a large game
publisher and you've already collected a
lot of player data Google Google Cloud
bigquery has a free bulk loading tool
where you can upload all of that data
into bigquery and then start slicing and
dicing it using sql-like queries with
the computational power behind them to
actually return the results
so you can start establishing a view of
what your players are doing in your game
a couple of quick things to note about
about bigquery is that one it's fully
managed and serverless and second
storage and compute are independent from
each other and can scale up or scale
down and on demand so that kind of
flexibility can save a lot of business
costs from from your side because you
don't have to invest upfront in building
their own infrastructure for logging or
storage pipelines to manage all this
data and of course storing that amount
of data is already a pain let alone
analyzing it to figure out what's going
on but maybe you're not ready to invest
a lot of logging infrastructure in the
game as you just released it right maybe
you just want to release your game and
start getting some kind of analytics
without having to invest in that logging
or storage pipeline infrastructure so
for such a situation you can use
something like Google Analytics for
firebase the way it works is pretty much
as soon as you add the firebase SDK to
your project you're gonna start getting
out-of-the-box events automatically
reported and when you log in your
firebase console you're gonna see these
reports automatically being generated
for your game so that includes things
like in-app purchase it purchase revenue
user engagement retention daily active
users and so forth but more importantly
analytics also allows you to use custom
events that you can log in your game as
well so those are things that are more
specific and interesting for your game
for mega hamster this might be things
like did anyone use the map editor did
someone create a map
how many times did they retry a level
before they gave up did they even manage
to finish the level you know which
levels did they select these kind of
things are custom events that you might
run record or that we'd run a record for
mega hamster and you can you can also
choose that for your own games and have
it available in the analytics dashboard
and then while we're talking about
creating these custom events you'll want
to mark some of these as conversion
events as well and you can do so in the
firebase console by hitting those
toggles at one second I'm trying to
click the thing okay sorry by hitting
those toggles those toggles to mark
whatever event
you're recording as conversion events so
those conversion events are the things
that are especially important for your
app and what you want to direct your
users to do so these could be things
like you know did they create an account
did they invite your friend to the game
or their friend of the game they give
preview currency to their games or give
something to their to their friends for
the game those kind of things sorry I
need to go back to one slide and the
other advantage with marking these
things of conversion events these
important things for your game is that
firebase can use that to feed that back
to any ad campaigns you have to attract
more users and it'll tailor the
audiences that it goes after they're
based on this conversion data that you
care about okay so with Google with
Google bigquery and with firebase
analytics you're starting to get a
picture you're going to be able to paint
a picture basically of what is going on
in your game and what your players are
doing so we kind of answered the first
part of this question of how can I track
how my game is doing now and once you
know that you want to look at the second
part of now how can I easily test new
features and see if those are good so
typically when you want to test a new
set of features you might have an alpha
or beta channel where you'll release
that new set of features and expose it
to a test group and that's well and good
but can often have a lot of overhead for
one you have to kind of match the
cadence of your team's release cycle to
get your build available for each of
these channels and then of course you
need different build variants that you
deploy to alpha or beta we can start
becoming a bit of a pain furthermore if
you're releasing a new feature and you
want to easily get feedback on it if
you're just releasing it to alpha a beta
users you might not be getting a large
amount of data versus your whole
audience or at least a larger percentage
of your audience we are getting the
feedback behind that new feature and
being able to determine more and
validate that it's working and then
here's another use case right what if
you want to you know just release a
temporary seasonal or promotional new
feature in your game so in the case of
mecha hamster
let's say we wanted to change the color
of the hamster ball to white and red
just for Canada today when it's Canada
Day in that users device on in the date
time of that users device and for a
Canadian users right oh sorry I go one
flight back so including that one you
one change once seasonal change or
temporary change into your build can
complicate that build because you've
already got a few things planned and
introducing this one new feature can add
some delay to that in addition to that
if you're if there's other higher
priority issues that come up for your
team's current builds this might get
dropped right there might be other
things that they have to focus on and
this is not so really something they can
do and then you're just losing it
entirely so for both of those use cases
when you want to release new features
and easily test them as well as for
seasonal changes you want to introduce
in your game
there's firebase remote config that we
wanted to kind of introduce so if you
haven't heard of this before you can
kind of think of it as a key value pair
that a key value store that lives in the
cloud and it allows you to control the
look and feel of your game or the
behavior of your game remotely without
having to rebuild different versions of
your of your app and deploy to all the
different channels and app stores so
this is the way it works going back to
our example for the candidate a hamster
ball here's some default values for what
the hamster ball looks like now right so
we've got ball color ball glow and ball
size as per ad remote config parameters
we defined with these defaults so
whenever the user starts up the phone
for the first time these are normally
the values that they'll see for their
ball next we introduce some new values
for the ball ball color being white and
Bodwell being red and we can condition
those or gate them on specific any kind
of conditions in this case it would be
that it is tanah today on the user's
phone on their date time on their device
and that they're located in Canada for
those users we want to push these values
these will then be waiting in the cloud
ready to replace the values that we've
set as the default and then when the
condition hits and everything is true
it'll combine those values
pull in the Delta and then change the
look of the ball for those Canadian
users another cool thing about the way
remote config works is that it only
downloads the Delta or the difference
the diff of the values for the remote
config variables and not the whole set
every time so you're not going to eat up
a lot of your user's data by using a
remote config now you might be thinking
wait a minute isn't this kind of like
feature rollout flagging and yeah it is
that's kind of the idea behind it so it
allows you to kind of easily you know
control feature rollouts for your game
without having to redeploy different
builds and enable and disable that via
the firebase console one thing I should
mention actually in the previous slide
can I go to slides back sorry
so those about new values that you set
you'd actually set those in the firebase
console directly so you can do it
through the firebase console or you can
do it via the REST API so that's how you
can set and condition than you values
you want to sit on okay so we kind of
saw a little bit of how to use remote
config for this kind of new seasonal
feature that we want to release for
Canada T but how how about like for more
general use cases there's some other
times i remote config can be helpful and
more importantly when you're testing or
releasing these new features you want to
get the feedback behind them so let's
take a look at that okay so taking a
look back at the custom events that I
created for Google Analytics for
firebase for Mecca hamster if you look
at the ones on the right hand side I'm
collecting retries whether the user
finished the level and what levels
they've selected well you could imagine
that you know let's say a user who just
started playing this game they have a
large number of retries for a given
level or they never did manage to
complete one or they've only selected a
certain group of levels that are fairly
easy to complete you can imagine that
those are kind of like beginners to my
game well one cool thing about the way
remote config and analytics works is
that it allows you to create different
audiences based on these custom events
you can filter or out-of-the-box events
as well in analytics in this case for
mecha hamster I'm creating a beginners
audience and I want to target remote
config
variables only to that audience I'm
defining that as any audio any players
who have a number of retries recorder
dates greater than five and who haven't
completed a level so identified this
beginner audience and for them I'm gonna
change the values of my remote config
parameters and set the ball size too big
and the gravity to 0.5 to make the game
easier for them to play okay so that's
cool right
I can easily release new things but what
about different variants that I want to
try so for example for my beginner
audience that new ball size and gravity
that I set might make the game like way
too easy for them and quite boring right
for for cases where I want to test
multiple variations or combinations of
these to see which one works best for my
beginner audience there's five as a/b
testing as well that works in
combination with row config and
analytics for that purpose and here are
the steps for setting up a B testing so
the first thing is you define your
target right whether that's 5% of your
total audience or whether that's all
your users who speak Korean you can set
that up however you like
for mecha hamster that's gonna be the
beginners audience that I defined
earlier step 2 is you create your
variants so again for mecha hamster that
would be different combinations of ball
sizing gravity so just to see which
combination works best for this beginner
group step three is to determine the
goal for your a B test so these can be
out-of-the-box goals that come from
analytics things like daily user
engagement and that kind of thing it can
also be custom events that you care
about so what is the goal what is the
thing that you want to measure with
these different variants to see if your
experiment is successful or not for
mecha hamster that would probably be
that I want my daily user user
engagement to increase I want the number
of retries to go down so that they're
having an easier time and I might add
secondary goals right for example user
retention is a secondary goal that I'd
add here because I want to make sure I'm
not negatively affecting the retention
of my game
among other beginners in
group who might find all those variants
boring it might stop playing the game
entirely so you can choose what goals
you want for your a/v test as well and
set those here and then the last step is
just to kind of wait and relax and let
the experiments run for a couple of
weeks and start generating some data
that you can look at by the end of that
you'll be able to determine if there's
one group that performs extremely well
and then roll that out as the new
control more broadly among your beginner
audience or whatever other audience you
define okay so thus far we're using
remote config to release new features
we're using a/b testing to test
different variants and figure out which
one works best and then roll that out
more broadly but this up to now has all
been reactive things we've been doing
for our players we've been seeing how
they've behaved so far and then choosing
to and then you know basically adding
new features based on what we've seen at
that point wouldn't be cool if we could
anticipate what they're gonna do and in
fact if we could predict the future and
predict how our users can behave instead
of reacting to it so Foley there was
someone who could tell us our futures
well there is and that's firebase
predictions another product available in
firebase so firebase can harness the
power of machine learning to create
groups of users who are predicted to
exhibit some kind of behavior in your
app the general idea is that as your
players are playing your game Google
Analytics is collecting a bunch of data
and storing that and then predictions
can take a look at that data to see if
there's any patterns that exist for
things that these players have done
before they took some other desired
action so let's say for example that
desired action is a player who spent
money in your game or made an in-app
purchase what what predictions will do
is go ahead and look at users who have
already made purchases and look at the
past data then it will use a neural
network powered by tensorflow
to see if there are any patterns that
these users have exhibited before they
made that purchase once it does that
it'll start making groups of users
categorized as likely spenders or
unlikely spenders
and once those groups have been
identified by predictions you can use
those groups in other features in
firebase and you can target those
predicted users who are predicted to
spend in your game so whether that's in
remote config or in a be tests you can
now choose that group and specifically
target different changes that you want
to roll out to just them so let's look
at a few examples of different
developers who have done this nope we're
gonna look at that later can I go back
one slide all right so how do you so how
do you enable this magic of machine
learning to your games do you have to go
back to school and take a neural network
submit programming class and and
graduate from that again it might not
hurt but you don't have to do any of
that you can actually just press this
button in the firebase console so once
you press this it turns predictions on
and from that point it's gonna start
collecting data and within a few weeks
you should have some predictions data
you can play with now out of the box the
two different events that predictions
works for is to determine spenders and
non spenders and also users who might
turn from your app or continue using it
but in addition to those you can use
other custom events that you care about
and use predictions to figure out if
those actions are likely happened as
well so those are those custom events
that I mentioned earlier that you would
mark as conversion events or things that
are particularly important for your game
so you can mark those and then
predictions will start training over
that as well okay so here's where I was
getting to earlier about examples of
different game publishers who have used
some combinations of these features to
realize some pretty good value so in
this case there's half brick what they
did is that they use predictions to
determine churners people who are likely
to stop playing their game and in that
group they targeted notifications where
that gifted them premium currency in
their game and in doing so they saw a
20% boost in seven-day user retention
and it performed better than a fixed
reward system that they had earlier
there's also Rock bite so they use a
combination of predictions and remote
fake and in their case they use the
groups that check for spenders and for
those that were determined to spend they
changed the store layout to better match
their their patterns and for those who
are determined to not spend they had it
differently out through the remote
config that they've configured and in
doing so they increase their
profitability and remain competitive and
a normally competitive already
competitive mobile gaming industry ok so
at this point let's say you've used
analytics to collect insights into your
data or Google Cloud bigquery and upload
your data to slice and dice it you're
using remote config a be testing to test
different variants and this is all great
and let's say as a result of this you've
got a lot of users and a lot of players
and that's fantastic that's kind of what
you want but now you've got a lot of
data right you've got a lot of players
and a lot of data that you've
accumulated across all these different
features so remember that the image of
that data center that I showed earlier
when I talked about a lot of features
and then I very sneakily introduced
bigquery well here's another example
where bigquery can help so firebase in
bigquery integrate really easily with
each other and you can export all those
different features that I just mentioned
so analytics data crashlytics data as
well as predictions data into bigquery
where you can slice and dice it for
other insights that you want to gain so
this is really useful because there's
some things that these dashboards
themselves might not do but that you
could write your own queries against to
figure out all kinds of things um here's
some examples so for analytics right if
you export your analytics data into
bigquery you can analyze user retention
trends for your game and identify root
causes behind them for crashlytics you
can segment crashes by levels libraries
or any other custom key that you include
in your crash logs
so whatever custom key you put in there
once you've exported your crashlytics
data into bigquery you can now use that
if you'd like to see okay level 3 has an
issue and level 3 is where most of these
crashes are happening fairly easily and
then for predictions one really
straightforward use case and a very
common one
is to identify your biggest spenders by
city or by country as by running a query
again in big query once you've exported
your data so this kind of wraps up
everything we wanted to share with you
guys
we hope just helped you feel excited
about using firebase for your games
we hope there's at least one or two use
cases where you can where you see it you
can use firebase to help in your game
development and hopefully you get
started and reach out to us when you
have any questions at the moment I think
we still have some time for Q&A if
there's any live Q&A you guys want to do
in the room otherwise we'll be just
outside of here I think they're closing
down this room at 6 o'clock so we'll be
just outside and hanging out if any if
you have any questions for us but let's
first I get to open the room and see if
anyone has any questions you guys are
back on the stage any questions on using
firebase going once going twice
awesome job okay oh I think there's a
mic coming as well just uh father folks
can hear ya
i does the unity plugin natively support
windows or just ios and android right
now I believe that just Android Android
iOS right right now he's just iOS
Android
okay so if I wanted to use Windows I'd
have to use the rap the C++ SDK I
believe C++ SDK right now is now all the
features are Specht out it's good enough
for you to like use in the unity editor
or to test and desktop but we're still
working on it
and it is open source now so if you go
faster than ah Steve can get there too
Thanks all right there any questions you
guys want to ask this in private we'll
be just outside also want to remind you
guys to scan your badges on the way out
just to make sure you get the evaluation
forms to give us feedback on the talk
and with that thank you again for
participating
also there's if you want to download
macam strand give it a try you can
download it from the App Store a Play
Store we also have all the code hosted
on get up there if you want to download
that bill didn't take the check it out
and to learn more about how firebase can
help with your games development there's
that URL right there Frey basic
google.com slash games and we've got a
booth and we're gonna be there most of
the week
it's in this building at spot p150 one I
think it's an yeah the South Pole is you
so we'll be there all that week you want
to come by and say hello
alright thank you very much